[Music]
the couple had left the Manhattan awards
ceremony just before 10 P.M
the flashes and clicks an indication of
the intense focus on them
[Music]
with their own private security they
left with Megan's mother no police
escort and that they say is when the
pursuit they claimed was near
catastrophic began from here they'd
planned to Drive North to stay at a
friend's house on the Upper East Side
but they say they were chased in what
they called a Relentless Pursuit that
were near misses with other cars with
pedestrians and with two police officers
the spokesman for the couple has said to
me that 12 photographers were chasing
them and that it left them in her words
incredibly scared and shaken up
it was dark when they drove through the
streets a few routes were made in an
attempt to lose the tail the couple did
not want their destination their
friend's home to be revealed
three times they came to this police
station in an attempt to lose the
photographers at one stage they left in
a Yellow Cab and we've seen the
paparazzi images from that taxi Prince
Harry filming them as they snapped him
speaking exclusively to Sky News his
spokesperson said there were several
times where the car stopped and security
got out there were instances where the
police confronted the paparazzi and had
asked them to stop or give them space to
do this safely unfortunately that wish
was not respected they were pretty
nervous you know but the security guard
he was on it and what did you think
about the description of this you know
the near catastrophic event oh I don't
think that's true I think that's all you
know exaggerated and stuff the city's
mayor described it all as Reckless and
irresponsible but he counted any
suggestion of a high-speed Pursuit I
would find it hard to believe that there
was a two-hour high-speed chase but if
it's uh 10 minutes a 10 minute Chase is
extremely dangerous in New York City
it's clear though that the couples see
direct parallels with Paris August 1997
and the chase which killed Harry's
mother and shifted the course of his
life since Harry has faced these
challenges since he was a young child
he's been in the public eye and will
continue to be in the public eye they
have to find the right balance doing the
things that are important to them in a
public role with the Privacy that they
crave we know from his book and the
Netflix series that he is used to
Pursuit that the sussexes claimed this
was of a different order it comes of
course as the prince continues his
Almighty Court battle with the British
press over privacy Mark Stone Sky News
in New York